so these are my visual poi by pyro Tara
light toys it's a simple idea but the
incredible results it's a wand of LEDs I
think it's 136 on visual point they're
controlled by a chip when you put an
image onto them and spin it it makes an
image in the air now there's different
companies doing this now but everywhere
I go all the professional performers I
go to they're using the visual point and
if you want to perform it's really worth
it because lots of places you can't do
fire this is a serious alternative to
fire pyro Tara they've been greatly than
sending the samples to the product over
the years and you've seen some of the
photos I've done with these and the
videos so finally I'm making a little
review saying what they are so fire tara
visual poi LEDs and wand images you can
program it it's like video editing it
really easy to lay your images along the
timeline upload it with piece of music
you can put the images along with the
music it's easy to learn how to do and
then you can make everything
choreographed and beautiful and
[Music]